reconciliation
reconciliation and integration is a
pathway towards wholeness
pathway towards
mental health
we're all after reconciliation we're all
after
positive catharsis right the place in
which thesis and antithesis is resolved
by synthesis
the place beyond duality a place of
wholeness of integration
integration of the shadow integration of
the light
where where our disjointment comes back
into alignment
and that's what we're all looking for
we're all
we're all desiring
of this experience of this threshold
crossing of this baptism that finally
will make us whole
and
[Music]
you know life throws you punches and
disjointment follows the fractures of
trauma are such that we experience a
schism
and we become
frightened even of ourselves we're no
longer safe in our own bodies and what
this does is it casts a shadow upon our
experience of the world we bring this
trauma to the doorstep of every moment
and so we become
afraid the world becomes hostile and
this this dark cloud of trauma that kind
of colors our windshield becomes our
interpretive framework it becomes our
lens of perception and as chris lethar
be wrote we see through our lenses and
we see with our lenses but we don't see
the lenses themselves and so that scary
world we're seeing through our lenses is
being shaped and informed and colored by
that lens but we don't realize that
anymore we've come to believe that the
lens is reality that the map is the
territory but this corrupted lens and
this corrupted map that's been that's
been severed and disjointed that's
experienced the schism of trauma the
rape the transgression the violation
that has brought us into disjointment
and dis congruence this is now coloring
our world the body keeps the score we
bring this gnawing anxiety and
self-consciousness with us to the
doorstep of every moment it's temporal
dislocation that's why david david
lanson calls it and in this temporal
dislocation we over determine the
present moment we misread the present
moment and so we're walking on eggshells
unnecessarily a victim of our own
self-defeating projections and we need
to break through this we need to break
past this to come back into wholeness
and so that map of the world that lens
of perception has to die we have to have
an experience that is akin to inverse
ptsd right an experience that is as
intense as the trauma was but it's
inverse and so what that does is it
bumps us up a level and now we can see
the lenses that we see through and with
we can actually see the lenses
themselves and once we see the lenses we
can dispense with those lenses and that
means we become twice born and now we
meet the world not with fear perhaps but
with curiosity and grace and equanimity
something has shifted from the inside
out and then everything changes right
and so that's what we're all after that
kind of healing that kind of reconciling
from disjoint or coming into congruence
coming into integrity are coming into
acceptance and coming into wholeness we
need to integrate all of us and come
back into that place we need to
reconcile we need positive catharsis
and and my whole life is is about that
journey right we're all on the eat pray
love journey you know the ironies that
these videos surf serve to me as
evidentiary
you know as evidentiary
footage you know that that that i'm i'm
trying to leave paper trails i'm trying
to map out the terrain right i'm trying
i'm trying to
i'm trying to to see if i can heal and
if i can come back into wholeness and if
i can reconcile and if i can do it you
can do it if we can do it well hey man
then
then
well then we stand a chance that
we stand a chance of
yeah of walking amongst gods
of
[Music]
returning to the garden of eden
of
experiencing moment by moment the
miracle of naked existence
to marvel
to awe
to feel
to know
that's what we want
that's what we want
that feeling
feeling at the end of the greatest film
you've ever seen
and
it's the end of the movie
[Music]
but everything is better now
and everything is going to be okay
[Music]
[Music]
that's called positive catharsis
[Music]
not gonna cry but i'm close
but i think that's what everybody's
everybody's after
how about this
[Music]
um
[Music]
the realization in the end
is that paradise
is not a place you
go but a way you feel for a moment in
your life when you're a part of
something
when you find that moment
[Music]
it lasts forever
it's just like so beautiful and then the
photograph appears and it says parallel
universe and her signature that shows
proof
that this was once real that we were
once whole
this really did happen we really did
meet
bittersweet happy sad
beautiful
so friends yes
i hope we all find that
i think we all are deserving of that
those moments
that
connection magic
romance freedom
[Music]
and abandonment ah